[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'attends de trouver tout genre
elle fait partie je me dis les
accoucheurs de tout cela on adore je
suis fou d'elle j'ai créé grosse
surprise pour vous shine tout leur ai
juste avant attention qu'est ce que ça
fait c'est gelé le pas de calais shine
moi j'adore vous voir dans ces chefs
vous voir chanter j'aime voir danser
jamais vous voir vous coiffer j'aime
pouvoir tout faire mais j'aime pouvoir
tout simplement oui alors j'aimerais
qu'avec hainaut reich ein on fasse un
amalgame dans ça s'appelle le freeze
dance c'est parti alors attention vous
n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas ensemble vous
êtes concurrents 40 ça veut dire
innocent même temps yes you do clutch
time un daeu quinquennat
ah oui j'aime bien ça c'est sexy sacha
rim mais pas et que je frise schyman
elle s'est prise et on dirait qu'elle
attend le bus mais c'est déjà bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai entendu là nous était à près de
s'arrêter
je vais quand même faire le taux de
charbon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ouais
maman bon je dis on devait faire trois
chansons je pense qu'on va en faire cinq
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon alors qu'est ce qu'elle veut boire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]